now turn our attention to other news
tonight in the media mob
we start with a blatant fact if you are
a self-proclaimed
journalist at the new york times
washington post
fake news cnn msdnc abc nbc cbs
you actually have two jobs one protect
democrats
especially joe biden at all costs
number two stall carrass smear slander
donald trump and his family
and anybody who supports him obviously
even though you call yourself
journalists
you're not that's not journalism and by
and large the
employees at the so-called news outlets
they're not
journalists we as i said in 2007
journalism is dead in america now this
week in two open letters
i asked maggie haberman ben smith that
the new york times
other self-proclaimed journalists there
uh about their beloved
russia hoax three years of never-ending
lies conspiracy theories that they
peddled
each and every day to the american
people and the differences
in coverage by the way the way they
treat joe biden versus the way they
treated donald trump
it is staggering instead of answering my
questions
mr prestigious holier than now uh
new york times calls himself a
journalist ben smith
you know that's the same guy that not
only released hillary clinton's bought
and paid for
dirty russian disinformation dossier but
said he believed it he said the broad
outline of the dossier
is unquestionably true ben do you stand
by that tonight
anyway he decided to try to change the
topic on social media
and attack yours truly and this new york
times reporter used and
now this is pretty funny the new york
times with all the prestige that they
like to think that they have
they're now tweeting out from an account
and using
an account on twitter that's called
their word is not mine
at pop [ __ ]
a twitter account with 34 000 followers
let me repeat
the new york times is now getting
information and passing on information
from a twitter account called at pop
[ __ ] you can't make this adam shift up
now the big news is that some people at
fox apparently don't like me
and said bad things about me gutlessly
behind my back according to ben smith to
members of the media mob ben if that's
true
that's called a normal day in the world
that i live in
and here's a little secret for you ben
and all the
liberals that hate watch this program
every night
i don't care i don't give a adam schiff
about what anybody says about me i've
been doing this show 25 years 33 years
in radio
i do this show i do my radio show i do
it for my audience the people
that have been so loyal to me and give
me this camera
every night and give me that microphone
every day and i do it loudly i do it
proudly and i do it unapologetically
and i'm not going to change just because
some of you don't like me
i'm open and honest about my
conservative beliefs
and who i support it's hardly a breaking
news alert ben
and unfortunately honesty and truth
that's not a priority for people at the
new york times like ben
and maggie and well the rest of the
media mob
over the past five years they got dozens
and dozens
and dozens of stories dead wrong cheryl
atkinson she has a running list on her
website
she's now up to i think 156 fake news
stories
and counting in 2020 multiple outlets
remember they claim
president trump forcefully uh cleared
peaceful protest
protesters out of lafayette park because
he wanted a photo op
well the inspector general said that's
fake news
the washington post others claiming that
the covet lab leak hypothesis
was nothing but a debunked conspiracy
theory
more fake news the new york times
implying that president trump had
paid no income taxes for 18 years well
that was proven to be
fake news there was fake news about the
first lady's immigration status
fake news about the president's children
fake news about
russian bounties on u.s soldiers fake
news about oh nicholas sandman
i can't wait to pay and fork over
millions to that
kid he deserves every penny and of
course years of fake news surrounding
something that never happened and that
was trump russia collusion
and the conspiracy theory that they
peddled almost every single day
which was derived from an actual russian
disinformation campaign
bought and paid for by hillary clinton
and
published publicly released and publicly
believed
by new york times writer whatever he is
columnist
he's not a journalist ben smith himself
so ben maggie the new york times
and the other russia collusion truthers
in the media mob
let me ask you one more time do you
still believe in the russia hoax
that you pedal to your audiences do you
still think the clinton steele dossier
is unquestionably true do you care about
premeditated fraud that was perpetrated
numerous times against the fisa court do
you care
will you now admit uh that candidate and
then later president trump was he
illegally spied on
because of hillary's dirty russian
disinformation dossier
and the lies told to the fisa court says
at the top of a fisa application
verified none of it was verifiable
do you care about government abuse of
power because up to now
you've shown no interest in what would
have been the biggest stories in your
career
will you try and ever ever hold biden
accountable for anything
will you investigate his corrupt
international family business
will you try and find out why sketchy
foreign nationals
let's see from kazakhstan russia
china ukraine why were they paying joe
biden's crack addicted son hunter
with zero experience millions and
millions of dollars
are you going to lift a finger and
investigate hunter's laptop from hell
will you hold biden accountable for his
race
racist rhetoric prior support for
segregation
will you ever do any of these things
will you conduct any investigation
surrounding the biden administration
now look at this according to a new
reuters poll the u.s now ranks
dead last in media trust by the way
that's because of the media mob the new
york times
the washington post abc cbs nbc
fake news cnn and msdnc and pretty much
the rest of the media
and by the way because you're all new
green deal socialist you have an agenda
you're not the journalist you claim to
be stop
pretending it's time to own who you are
own it
own your truth the times propagated in
actual hoax
they did it for years as did these other
outlets in the case of the new york
times they had pulled surprises for
their efforts
so the other question we have for you
maggie haberman ben smith
dean baquette uh if you had any decency
any honor you and your colleagues would
give back what is a
phony pulitzer prize will you do it now
one last question
will you do the right thing at the new
york times will you
give the pulitzer prizes back we're not
holding our breath
now of course cnn's humpty dumpty's real
job is to be
mr potato head jeff sucker stenographer
well
he will not be holding his colleagues in
the media mob accountable
it's like this blue checklist cult you
know it's they
they live in their isolated fake news
media bubble
and i'll tweet your article that's fake
if you tweet my fake article
he has more important things to do like
stalking yours truly and watching fox
news
24 7. now recently poor humpty
had to take some time away from watching
fox he went on his nationwide book
tour for his re-released anti-trump
anti-fox diatribe i'm told a whopping 13
brand new chapters
wow a lot of work now unfortunately
sad news for humpty tonight because
despite numerous national tv appearances
tons of hype poor humpty dumpty only
managed to sell
yeah a meager 1 300
1738 copies in the first week of sales
and he's actually 4007 on
amazon.com well behind every other book
ever written
and tonight by the way more bad news for
humpty dumpty new york magazine is
actually reporting
i didn't know that he had family members
in the news business
but apparently his wife is an anchor on
some channels somewhere
and she's being accused of bullying and
creating a toxic
environment in her workplace now here's
the question humpty dumpty hosts a show
about the media
i wonder if he will cover this big media
story
on his low-rated media show i wouldn't
hold my breath
now ultimately the bryan humpty dumpty's
of the world
the maggie habermans the ben smiths of
the world everyone else in the media mob
they can cover whatever they want it's a
free country freedom of the press
freedom of speech i believe in all of it
i never support
boycotts i never call for cancellations
but if they were decent
and ethical and if they were true
journalists as they claimed
that they are they would at least be
honest about their own political agenda
they could at least be honest about that
little part they have an opinion
they offer their opinion they have an
agenda they follow it every day
i'm honest with my audience i am a talk
show host
yes i'm a member of the press i do
straight news i can produce
thousands of hours of covers of coverage
radio and tv
we do investigative reporting actually
this show
got the quote trump russia collusion
story right
we were proven right you were proven
wrong i give opinion
i openly say i am a proud conservative
i'm like the entire newspaper i'm honest
you though claim to be something you're
not you claim to be
journalists and that is just straight up
not true
you have an abusively biased socialist
agenda hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else